the fast saga might be coming to a close
but the next flick in the main series
still might not be the last in keeping
with the franchise's more is more
aesthetic star Vin Diesel has suggested
that fast 10 might be split into two
parts
he made his remarks in a recent
wide-ranging interview with total film
magazine the bombshell about the final
fast flick came as diesel was discussing
possibilities for the future of the
franchise which he hopes will extend
long beyond the life of the main series
in the form of spin-offs of course the
first of these Fast and Furious presents
Hobbs and Shaw hit theaters last summer
pleasing the heck out of audiences and
cleaning up at the box office to the
tune of 760 million dollars worldwide no
doubt fans were shouting make more no
one tells you what to do anyway
diesel said the universe is so robust
and so rich with talent and rich with
story that on one level it's totally
feasible to have spin-offs and I think
that's something that is inevitable
Studio Universal deserves it because of
how much they've invested in this little
saga and it'd be good to give back to
Universal and for the fans should fast
10 parts 1 & 2 be the conclusion it
would be nice for this world to continue
for generations to come
generally speaking two-part conclusions
are more commonly associated with film
adaptations of popular books and since
none but the final volume in each series
ever seems to require the two-part
treatment the strategy can be seen as
something of a cash grab perhaps the
most famous example is Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows a novel which
dedicates an absurd amount of its length
to character's wandering around in the
woods and which it could be argued
really didn't need a pair of to our
films to tell its story more recently
The Hunger Games Mockingjay was split
into two parts which doesn't seem quite
so egregious the novel is slightly more
narrative ly dense and as there are only
three books in the series it's
understandable that the movies producers
would seek to give audiences more to
chew on strangely though in the case of
Potter the strategy paid off
but for Hunger Games not so much Deathly
Hallows part-2 was by far the highest
grossing film in the series with part 1
coming in third behind Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone my contrast
Mockingjay part 2 was actually the
series lowest grossing entry with part 1
coming in second behind Catching Fire
of course Hunger Games wasn't quite the
box-office force that Potter
so the not-so-surprising takeaway here
is that the greater your franchises
cultural reach the more likely it is
that audiences will shell out for two
tickets to see the conclusion of the
story with a worldwide gross of nearly
six billion dollars and the two most
recent entries in the main series having
cleared 1 billion dollars globally the
fast franchises one for which the
strategy could pay off big-time
obviously box office numbers like that
tend to prompt Studios to look for ways
to extend franchises for as long as
possible which brings us to those
spin-offs Hobson Shah is for the time
being the number for all time earner in
the series behind only Fast and Furious
6
the fate of the Furious & Furious 7
Dwayne the rock Johnson is a top
box-office draw his co-star Jason
Statham looks ready to keep kicking ass
forever and the two have excellent
on-screen chemistry it wouldn't surprise
us at all if Hobson Shaw were to become
its own franchise
and while no sequel has yet been
confirmed the flicks three post-credit
scenes sure seemed to be setting one up
here's what has been confirmed according
to Entertainment Weekly and as yet
untitled all-female spin-off is likely
to Center on Michelle Rodriguez as Letty
diesel himself has talked up the project
and it's currently being scripted by
guardians of the galaxy writer Nick Cole
Pearlman Lindsay beer was currently
working on the upcoming Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles reboot and Geneva
Robertson dwara who penned Captain
Marvel with a wealth of great characters
to choose from the fast universe could
spin off in untold directions once the
main series comes to a close heck those
spin-offs might even introduce new
characters which could receive spin-offs
of their own in the future as long as it
keeps bringing the high-octane action
fans will keep lining up for the latest
installment and speaking of which I may
want to mark your calendar f9 comes
roaring into theaters on May 22nd 2020
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff for coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]